U.S. DEFENSE SECRETARY LLOYD
AUSTIN SAYS SOME OF RUSSIA'S
ACTIONS IN UKRAINE AMOUNT TO
ATROCITIES.
HE SAID THIS TODAY DURING
INTERNATIONAL SECURITY FORUM
WHERE HE REAFFIRMED NATO'S
SUPPORT FOR UKRAINE.
>> RUSSIA IS JUST RAGING A WAR
OF AGGRESSION.
IT IS ALSO DELIBERATELY
ATTACKING SOME OF CIVILIAN
TARGETS AND CIVILIAN
INFRASTRUCTURE WITH NO MILITARY
PURPOSE WHATSOEVER.
NOW, THESE AREN'T JUST LAPSES.
THESE AREN'T EXCEPTIONS TO THE
RULES.
THESE ARE ATROCITIES.
>> SECRETARY AUSTIN WENT ON TO
WARN OF WHAT HE CALLED A
DANGEROUS SPIRAL NUCLEAR
PROLIFERATION AMONGST OTHER
COUNTRIES RULED BY AUTOCRATS.
CNN IS REPORTING THAT THE U.S.
IS RUNNING LOW ON ADVANCED
WEAPONS AND AMMUNITION'S
SYSTEMS THAT HAVE BEEN CRITICAL
TO UKRAINE'S SUCCESS ON THE
BATTLEFIELD, JOINING US NOW TO
TALK MORE ABOUT THIS IS CNN
MILITARY ANALYST, RETIRED AIR
FORCE COLONEL CEDRIC LEIGHTON.
OKAY, CEDRIC, HOW ARE YOU
CONCERNED ABOUT THESE SHORTAGES
AND IF THEY CAN POSSIBLY CHANGE
MOMENTUM IN THIS CONTEXT?
>> YEAH, I AM ACTUALLY VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS.
ONE OF THE KEY THINGS TO LOOK
AT IS THAT THESE ARE THE TYPES
OF WEAPONS SYSTEMS THAT ARE
BEING USED BY US RIGHT NOW.
SO WE HAVE GOT HOW IT'S --
THE 150 MILLIMETER VARIETY
STINGER, AND THE AIRCRAFT
MISSILES.
THESE ARE OF COURSE CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT AND THEY HAVE BEEN
TALKED ABOUT QUITE A BIT.
ANTI RADIATION MISSILES KNOWN
AS HARMS.
THE SURFACE TO SURFACE MISSILES
THAT ARE PART OF THE HIMARS
SYSTEM.
AND OF COURSE, THE JAVELIN
SYSTEMS.
SO THESE HAVE BEEN CRITICAL
FORCE ENABLERS FOR THE
UKRAINIANS.
SO FAR WE HAVE SPENT 18.3
BILLION DOLLARS ON THE UKRAINE
WAR SINCE FEBRUARY 24TH.
NOW, THAT IS DEFINITELY GONNA
BE GOING UP.
BUT THE OTHER THING THAT YOU
HAVE TO ASK YOURSELF IS, WHAT
IS GIVING US MORE BANG FOR THE
BUCK COMPARED THIS TO
AFGHANISTAN.
WHERE WE THREW A LOT OF MONEY
INTO AFGHANISTAN.
UP TO A TRILLION DOLLARS
ACCORDING TO SOME ESTIMATES.
THIS RIGHT HERE, THIS IS A LOT
LESS THAN THAT.
>> YEAH, I MEAN, IT IS
BILLIONS.
BILLIONS ARE A LOT.
BUT RELATIVELY SPEAKING, IT IS
KIND OF SMALL.
THE OTHER ISSUE, AND WE HAVE
TALKED A LOT ABOUT THIS, THE
POLITICAL INFLUENCE OF THIS
MOST RECENT ELECTION.
ACTUALLY, PAMELA BROWN SPOKE
WITH CONGRESSMAN JAMES COMER.
HE IS THE INCOMING.
WE EXPECT THE INCOMING
OVERSIGHT CHAIRMAN.
AND HE WAS TALKING WITH HER
ABOUT HOW SUPPORT FOR UKRAINE
MAY CHANGE.
MAYBE IT WON'T, WE WILL SEE
WHEN THE GOP TAKES CONTROL.
HERE IT IS.
>> SOON TO BE SPEAKER MCCARTHY
HAS SAID HE WON'T GIVE UKRAINE
A BLANK CHECK HAS THINGS
ESCALATE WHAT DO YOU THINK IS
THE BEST APPROACH?
SHOULD THE U.S. DO MORE TO HELP
UKRAINE HOLD LOTTERY PUTIN
ACCOUNTABLE?
>> WELL, WE ALL SUPPORTED
UKRAINE AGAINST RUSSIA, RIGHT?
WE HAVE GIVEN THEM A LOT OF
MONEY.
AND ONE THING THAT REPUBLICANS
ARE ASKING FOR IS AN AUDIT.
WE NEED TO KNOW, WE HAVE GIVEN
THEM BILLIONS AND BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
WHERE HAS IT GONE?
DON'T SAY, ALL RIGHT, WE HAVE
SPENT 45 BILLION ON ARMS AND 15
BILLION ON HUMANITARIAN RELIEF.
THAT IS NOT SPECIFIC ENOUGH.
SO YOU GIVE US AN ACCOUNTING,
AND I THINK THERE WILL BE MORE
SUPPORT MOVING FORWARD FOR
THAT.
BUT UNTIL THERE IS A FULL
ACCOUNTING AND AN INSPECTOR
GENERAL, THAT IS WHAT MOST, YOU
KNOW, BIG PROJECTS LIKE THIS
HAVE.
I DON'T THINK THERE IS GONNA BE
A LOT OF SUPPORT FROM
REPUBLICANS.
>> ALL RIGHT, SO LISTENING TO
WHAT HE IS SAYING, WHAT ARE
YOUR CONCERNS?
SO THE MAIN THING THAT I HEARD
IN THAT WAS THE VERY LAST
SENTENCE WHERE HE SAID, I DON'T
THINK THERE WILL BE A LOT OF
SUPPORT FROM REPUBLICANS.
WHAT'S THE KEY THING TO THINK
ABOUT HERE IS WHAT ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT.
IF WE DON'T GIVE SUPPORT TO THE
UKRAINIAN WAR EFFORT, THESE
GAMES THAT WE SEE RIGHT HERE,
THAT THE UKRAINIANS WERE ABLE
TO ACHIEVE AROUND KHARKIV AND
WHAT THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO DO
AROUND HER SON AND DO WE LOOK
AT THIS FROM A PERSPECTIVE IN
THE SOUTH.
THESE ARE SIGNIFICANT.
AND THEY WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
POSSIBLE IF IT HAD NOT BEEN FOR
THESE WEAPONS.
SO IF THE REPUBLICANS ARE
SAYING THAT THEY ARE NOT GONNA
SUPPORT ANYTHING UNTIL THEY GET
A FULL ACCOUNTING, THAT IS
GONNA BE A TALL ORDER TO DO IT.
THEY SHOULD GET EQUAL
ACCOUNTING.
BUT TO ASK THE UKRAINIANS TO DO
IT WOULD BE A MISTAKE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE WILL
HAVE TO DO IT.
AND THERE ARE SOME QUESTIONS AS
TO WHETHER OR NOT THEY CAN
ACTUALLY DO THAT AT THIS TIME.
>> VERY GOOD EXPLANATION OF
THAT.
SO OF COURSE IN UKRAINE, WINTER
IS UPON THE UKRAINIANS.
AND YOU SEE RUSSIA ATTACKING
THINGS THAT ARE GONNA GET MAKE
THAT REALLY TOUGH.
ON THE CIVILIAN POPULATION, NOT
JUST ON THE MILITARY
POPULATION.
AND I THINK, THOUGH, I WONDER
IF YOU THINK THAT THAT IS
ACTUALLY GOING TO EFFECT
THINGS.
BECAUSE OF ANYTHING, THE
UKRAINIANS HAVE SHOWN US HOW
TOUGH THEY ARE.
TOUGH IT WITHSTANDING
CHALLENGES THAT OFTENTIMES
PEOPLE THINK WOULD BREAK THEM.
AND IT JUST DOESN'T.
>> THAT IS RIGHT, AND I THINK
THERE IS A BIT OF A PRECURSOR
HERE IN HISTORY TO THIS, WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE BOMBING
CAMPAIGN FOR WORLD WAR II.
HE FOUND THAT THE CIVILIAN
POPULATIONS THAT WERE IMPACTED
BY THESE BOMBING CAMPAIGNS WERE
ACTUALLY PRETTY RESILIENT, AND
THEY WERE ACTUALLY, THE RESULT
ACTUALLY TOUGHENED AND
STIFFENED THE MORE THESE
BOMBING CAMPAIGNS OCCURRED.
AND THIS KIND OF SAME
PSYCHOLOGICAL RESPONSE TO WHAT
IS HAPPENING NOW IN UKRAINE
WITH THE RUSSIANS ATTACKING
THEM AND THEIR INFRASTRUCTURE
AREAS ALL OVER THE COUNTRY.
GO TO LVIV, GO TO KYIV, KHARKIV,
GO TO THE MIDDLE OF THE
COUNTRY.
ALL OF THESE DIFFERENT PLACES
ARE BEING IMPACTED.
YOU KNOW, YOU HAVE GOT OVER 10
MILLION PEOPLE, AT LEAST,
IMPACTED BY.
THIS ABOUT A QUARTER OF THE
POPULATION IMPACTED BY PAREDES
ON A FAIRLY CONSISTENT BASIS.
THAT IS SIGNIFICANT.
BUT NEVER ONCE HAVE I HEARD
UKRAINIAN SAY THAT THEY ARE
GONNA GIVE UP BECAUSE OF THESE
EVENTS.
>> IT BLOWS YOUR MIND, AND YOU
CAN'T REALLY UNDERSTAND IT
UNTIL YOU SPEAK TO UKRAINIANS,
RIGHT?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> WHEN I WENT TO UKRAINE, THAT
WAS THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
THAT I THINK I WALKED AWAY WITH.
JUST UNDERSTANDING THAT RESULT.
IT IS BECAUSE THEY ARE FIGHTING
FOR A FUTURE GENERATION.
>> THEY ARE FIGHTING FOR THEIR
CHILDREN.
THEY DON'T WANT THEIR KIDS TO
HAVE TO PUT UP